welcome back
to the 2021 director's close-up this
week we are celebrating writers
thank you all for being here i i guess i
write to make sense of myself in the
world
for me i don't really want to make
something unless i
feel a deeper journey i've always felt
strong desire to want to escape into my
own
little weird world and maybe a tinge of
a god complex as well that i'd
honest through playing a lot of the sims
writing was sort of like a first refuge
for me
you know i think the stories that i tend
to gravitate towards are things that i
i want to see in the world i was always
drawn to world creation
creating a new world of possibilities
that could then explore
so i i think that's why i got uh into
fiction
writing as well i like dividing things
up into like the 30 minute mark with 60
minute mark
90 minute mark that would be like my
references to oh something needs to
crack something needs to happen
surround yourself with people that
believe in the project i have nothing
poetic to say there just
someone else but someone else cut me off